and we are live flashpoint is back after
the two-week hiatus advances what's
going on sir no well heads up guys it's
gonna be a long point we've got a lot to
talk about
but it's been a good couple of weeks had
a quick trip and you did as well so I
know you jumped up to pax you have a
good time up there I mean still I'm
still kind of like I don't wanna call it
jet lag road lag I'm still kinda like
getting my sleep schedule adjusted you
know that pax was fantastic shut up to
the Lords gaming etiquette a chat what's
up and um yeah it was really fun got a
chance to see him play a whole lot of
stuff was hoping Bungie would have a
presence but unfortunately they didn't
they announced and stuff we're not there
but other than that it was it was dope
really cool experience what about you
what you been up to uh trip for a family
thing so did that and came back our I
got the joys of being frisked at the
airport so that was a blast I have no
idea what was going on that morning
there was a lady and we were going
through the security of mine and I swear
it was every third person she would like
find a way to pull you to the side you'd
have to wait get your bag fully
inspected get a full pat-down and it was
like every third person cuz when I was
up there and it was my turn there was
like a sheet of paper and you're looking
up there and she's like initially and I
swear she was just trying to knock out
everything for the day in the first two
hours because it was like every three
minutes there was a new name and new
initials and we just were like backed up
waiting I'm like what the hell we were
there like an hour and fifteen minutes
early and we like got to our gate as it
was starting to board in or just like
didn't get food or anything by the time
we landed it was just yeah not a great
start to a trip but you're paying buddy
payment you know well we get a lot in
the world of this need to talk about
we're gonna take it back a week just
because we haven't had a chance to talk
about this stuff so we'll try and cover
this stuff a little quicker but we'll
definitely have some topics of
conversation as we go through so first
we're gonna jump back to the weekly
update for April 5th so this is the day
after they did the bungee bounty so as
you guys know they had Josh Hamrick and
Kevin Haines literally answering
questions in between the match
during the stream so in case you did
miss the stream I went and checked it
out later it's very cool so if you want
to hear in full detail but basically
what they did is they broke down all the
questions that were asked from twitch in
places and they were asking throughout
the stream and they basically
consolidated it so you could read it so
okay oh you don't have to go watch a
two-hour stream just to catch the codes
we don't want to do that it was we long
point enough we've got to gotta keep the
flash point yeah so now some of the
stuff may kind of duplicate so let me
skip over a couple questions just
because we're gonna talk about a little
bit later with other announcements that
came but just as the questions go
they're the ones in yellow so and then
the text is below that so we got in
regards to time to kill is it's a pretty
popular opinion within the community the
time to kill should be decreased from
what you feel so far since you've been
playing what do you think since one
point one point four came out I'm
indifferent I mean I get it with the
whole you know people want time to kill
to increase um yeah excuse me yeah but I
think it's like ultimately I think I
think the real issue is I think teen
shouting just plays more of a factor as
opposed to the tangka listen if they do
it is what do you think I am truly
indifferent because if they do it I'm
not gonna be upset if that's what the
community has a whole once by all means
go for it increase the time kill but um
I think the issue when destiny to you
just feel that team shouting is the way
to go and I've known for whatever it
just feels stronger you know I mean so
as opposed to d1 I mean obviously you
know d1 you got a two-on-one it wasn't
gonna go well but for some reason you
felt like you had a chance
whereas in d2 you don't you don't really
show that way well I mean it's like if
I'm gonna sit there I don't run sniper
that much in d2 but also I swear there
are not that many maps where there's
just lanes to snipe in d2 but in general
I mean I always think of like Pantheon
as literally a sniper math and if it was
like me and most of the team went to the
lower yeah lower of the two main runs
I usually don't consider the outside but
if those three of them we're down there
towards the water and everything I can
take the upper area and if I was like on
that that day I literally just lock that
place down and I'm by myself with a
sniper rifle
yes and those are those moments where
it's like okay this area is shut down
now go face my other team they are doing
a team thing but you got one running up
with a shotgun who's pushing you've got
somebody holding the other side down
with the sniper just those variances of
above play style aren't there it's like
yeah we're just gonna shoot scout rifle
shots back and forth of range but that's
all you're gonna do you're just gonna
trade and there's a lot of there is a
lot of training
I mean yep some people are better than
others but you don't as they go those
hero moments aren't there those single
shot kills don't happen as often yeah I
agree
so yeah I mean I'm kind of a few like
time to kill being decreased I'd be okay
with it
but I think it's more there are bigger
changes and we'll come to those later
they got wool vigilance wing which is a
very popular gun right now pretty hard
yeah I know a PC I have it obvious or if
I'm on PC I don't have it so much but
yeah I mean it's like tactically it can
hit it to [ __ ] to burst kill now that's
technically you're doing all headshots
trying to do that at range with a five
burst like a five shot pulse rifle it is
almost impossible so it's gonna be a
three shot it's still fast and powerful
but the nice thing is they said will you
be reigning it in are you gonna be
tuning it and they're like people like
it we don't want to do our whack-a-mole
thing again so they're actually looking
to bring other weapons up to it so we
clearly Tzadik tuning that they're doing
doing they're gonna [ __ ] and then this
unfortunately they phrase it in a weird
way he's like I believe you'll find a
few returned dings retuned exotics I can
do that the same thing that vigilance
wing can right now but Emily says a few
I'm going why isn't on all whom yeah
that is good don't worry me maybe they
just haven't touched them all yet but
we'll see we'll see what if mid it was a
free shot kill I just break the whole
game yeah at all you can't no way so you
could turn the game right all speaking
discussed it so it's just nice they're
not doing the whack-a-mole so it's good
to see that they're trying that continue
bring more things up so I like vanities
so they're asking about the stream for
expansion to we have more details on
that later so Network
there we get that uh so they asked which
element that the team has worked on that
they've enjoyed the most and Kevin gains
that said specifically the crucible
ranks so I know a lot of people want a
reason to play cruising well it's cool
to go in there have some fun
but you know the grind just like in PvE
if you have a reason to go for a be like
hey I'm going for that top crucible or
I'm going to try and hit the highest
number when you got a crucible rink
because it's a valour and glory yeah
right I think glorious rank and if your
glory is like you know one of the
highest ones out there and you're
holding it you're still playing it's
like that's gonna show and give people a
little a little more incentive to like
keep with it so again a really good step
in the direction and I I guess I'm kind
of surprised it's taken him this long to
do a rink since it's been asked for yes
I remember I was and II was like yeah it
was kind of like early in the the
roadmap when it was mentioned but I'm
good to hit him talking about it this is
definitely for me you know shout out to
uh my true meaning of war bounty
veterans this is kind of stuff we want
we want to be recognized when a grind
that crucible and then have a ranking
system to show it so love love that
can't we finish stuff to be implemented
somebody says I really wish duty weapon
systems were to turn the primary special
no it was better than the current one is
my works reasonable so we know you want
more loadout control you can expect
weapons lot changes in the future of
YouTube we will cover that later but and
we've covered it before people say do
you want to go back to the d1 primary
special heavy do you want to go back do
you want to go to a four slot system
either way just as we were saying above
we want some variety in our gameplay and
I think that's gonna be the biggest
thing that the weapon slots will help
with yes
can I be curious how they implemented
that yeah I'm so I'm kind of why we do
it now we'll get there we get a whole
development roadmap and it's a big plan
so yeah a question was what is the exact
design philosophy that lets you
determine when a balanced change is good
when testing what testing procedures do
you follow people want to know why some
things take so long no a complicated
game but a six month patch for a sandbox
update have
that's I think everybody's gonna agree
it's too long like it's messing on
fortnight's down the street doing it and
like on the fly in a week like they
gotta get with the times man I mean no
disrespect
we are not devs you know we we we we
just got it we there has to be a way for
that to be expedited just for the health
of the game you know that has to happen
they have to figure that out
we cannot be waiting six months for
sandbox updates and then you know
waiting longer
whenever the other changes need to be
made needs to be much more spontaneous
yeah it's like you got on board testers
all the time and it doesn't I think cuz
you read through here and you say what
so at any given moment they're working
on numerous sandbox updates the follow
the same pipeline first we set our goals
that we want to accomplish I said for
one point one point four rigs for
example they said they won't affect the
pace of combat more powerful and heroic
moments of which the pace that don't
increase the speed the works we cover
that later you know but in season three
they said they'll be delivering a round
of exotic weapon tuning intended to make
them feel more exotic which yes please
can't wait yes about but those ways
could say with our goals defined we make
the changes play test in the iterate as
long as we can I think that's one of the
issues they do it for as long as they
possibly can it's like you've got to be
okay throwing stuff out there if you get
the next week like break it break off it
it's a little too much then okay next
week we pull it back a bit yes if they
gotta let the reins go man like the baby
live like you know let them grow up let
them develop like they're so controlling
with this part it really affects
interesting game for sure and they say
from any of those changes we also test
our game now it's like we know the tests
are gonna happen you know they have a
lot of systems that are basically in
play so you've got PVE pvp crucible
nightfall straight out to break so try
not to break too much stuff it's not
just like fortnight in a battle royale
correct are we balanced in PvE or PvP no
headshots are crazy nobody's gonna do a
thousand damage with a pistol cool like
those things aren't there but again they
a lot more pieces so I understand it's
gonna take a little bit longer but as
yours I'm on your board I'm on board
with you as well it's like sometimes you
gotta let things happen it's like we had
the laser tag that was fun for a week in
there like caves I'm broke
enjoy it personally like they can do hot
fixes or they can do back in things just
deactivate a gun or something like that
if one thing breaks or one class type of
scout rifles is too crazy just like turn
it off for a little bit be like hey and
we're gonna patch it we'll turn them
back on on Tuesday next week it'll just
be off for like four or five days
exactly when they had to do that with a
d1 Hunter's Night Stalker glitch if you
like just eliminate an old for a little
bit a little bit I think just didn't
work for a while so same thing so again
I don't know the process we've heard so
many things about you know D ones engine
taking eight hours to up to load like a
map so you could make a change hoping
they changed it for d2 but it's just so
many of those things you wonder it's
like what why why and again this is the
point where it's like I don't want to
like berate them with like hey this
terrible I just literally want to sit
down be like I want to know the process
mm-hmm systems involved so I can at
least be like sorry I don't understand
so the next question was any plans for
the development team to get more
directly involved with the community
they mentioned things like the Bungie
bounties so people can actually chat
while they're playing they also kind of
tease at the idea of actually getting
content into our players hands before it
releases so they know there's a big
desire for testing builds early and
that's something I'm thinking about now
for them to release the reins like that
on a public test server is you know
tough but does I think other podcasts
have said that I've listened to don't
release the story content do that
testing in-house don't really spoilers
if you want to chest the sandbox you
want to test like a PvP map or something
like that let that out there in the wild
that's exactly it just gonna get a
little more hype up there later ly then
it's gonna release it more people play
so
last what can they tell us about the
solutions for loot systems random roles
perks all that fun stuff and Josh
hammered flat outside he's like I'm not
an investment designer that's not what I
do he said they are looking at trying to
get more reasons to play it wants you to
you know get excited for them you know
and begun to drop in things so they are
working on a lot of stuff and we'll get
to that here a little bit later as well
yes I know we're saying a little bit
later I'm just trying to work through
this stuff for you guys we're gonna
connect you the more recent information
you know now here is the question that
will peak some interest for a lot of
people ask are there any set plans to
introduce new elements classes
subclasses or weapon types to the game
in the near future straight-up just said
yes to some of those some of one some
yeah so be a weapon types or subclasses
or elements or enemies get an idea
he says he's like from my desk right now
I can look around and see new stuff on
several people screen so shown enough in
the months to come
so we'll probably we might see a little
bit for what's to come here in May and
then the fall is hopefully gonna have
something major I am kind of curious and
I'll give you a hats off I mean it looks
like something's happened in September
we'll just see if it's enough so
absolutely something def was cooking up
there's no doubt about it and I like
that question I mean you know elite we
don't know which one's gonna be you know
whether it be subclasses weapon types
you know I prefer it not be weapon types
at this might feel like they kind of
oversaturated at that we've got pretty
much every level in there on it I want
more unique weapons of the types we've
got like I talked about for those
nightfall rewards but I will say this
elements and subclasses new subclass and
alibied that would lose life becomes
life now I would love it if it was
actually a whole new class yes that
would give you a fourth character slots
so late I want to see I mean you have a
Titan you have a warlock and a hunter
I'm like I'm just trying to think in the
pantheon of those type of names what's
another class that even fits in those I
mean I go about ways back to Diablo so
it's like your warriors your wizards
things like that but it's not quite to
that like yeah it would be fantasy level
so I'm trying to think in a sci-fi
setting I would do that would have to be
taken Queen DLC you oh for sure yeah
I think so but it would be interesting
because they would have to kind of
create lower on the fly so this week
some unexplained this one dude we
thought yeah and we brought him out of
hiding for some time came back and we're
gonna teach you the ways of this like
yeah they'd have to some long-lost
whatever was coming packets black you
never know about the race class guard
yeah actually would be a name that would
fit of all the ones I like baby buns
Titan Hunter warlock Wraith
oh I but I was like but it they could
tweak that in a way that I could see a
fitting in this universe like wizard
stuff like that doesn't but raised I
like that that's me and Ibaka's are
ready to be on that team for ideas to
help them out let's go alright so next I
said how did the crucible team decide on
random game owns the biggest thing they
wanted is matchmaking times in
connection quality so connection quality
I understand people harp on that for all
the time on console and as I'm on PC
more I probably don't even feel it as
much
PC I honestly feel like connection is
never an issue for me I don't feel like
I'm dealing with lag I don't and that's
another reason why again not saying PC
master-race but literally I think you
just use your no it's cuz you're going
through battlenet and if you want to
have a better service than battle and
that good luck finding it mmm-hmm now I
still don't know if PC is done on
peer-to-peer as the same way console is
but just the fact that pcs typically and
maybe either process more handle more or
the PC people just may have like they
have a PC it's like okay I want a faster
connection I don't know if it's just
that level I don't know if all those
pieces make the connection quality on is
something I don't even think about
matchmaking times unfortunately PC on
the other hand are a bit longer because
I hear the player base they're smaller
this is my smaller right so you kind of
give-and-take either way on those but
those are two things that they I mean
people hooked on connection forever it's
like are you red bar in a d1 are you
doing that
I mean they wanted to try and find a way
to do that unfortunately in turn when
you like Corrales into a couple options
we're like I just want to go play
control and I can it's like I would
sometimes so yeah hopefully maybe
they'll do you know maybe one other
rotating playlist at some point but
they're just trying to make it to where
connections still good and the options
are there yeah how about dedicating
service how about it but I digress we've
all it's like we've all asked and
there's a point for I don't know if the
but I got here yeah I gotta keep the
bone a neck man like d3 come on now by
the time d3 well around I don't want to
give up you know that's just me
I don't know yeah I don't know why you
couldn't yeah there's no reason you
making hand-over-fist this is the number
one then the numbers did come out even
though its decline right now but it was
like the number ones most celled sold
game of 20 2017 and it wasn't even the
whole year didn't finish at that point
yeah it was basically number two behind
call of duty or something like before
act which can't afford it was like I
always wondered too I mean call of duty
is dedicated right I think still not
maybe it's an act
it's an Activision thing yeah it's
definitely an Activision thing and it's
a shame because this game they need you
know they need to put the money back
into the game and there's no reason in
this day and age what I mean even
rainbow succeeds is using Microsoft
Azure dedicates I mean come on you know
even if you don't want to house it
yourself you know the highlight Maxwell
do something and that's one PlayStation
idiot using microfiber is as well that
rainbows romances that's their developer
and that's what they're doing so no I'd
be nice
they did say people also asked about hey
what about making Rumble permanent they
said that so absolutely heard that
feedback I mean they heard it from day
one would be like we want this all the
time they're having conversations
they're thinking about it but I know
right now I guess they're just trying to
rotate through options which also we'll
cover later gives them a way to control
sheets and things like week on week off
which has some benefits to it I guess
but we'll say well they need to get that
done too
I think that's more of a playlist I mean
our community issue as well yeah Richard
I didn't want to separate them the asked
are you looking at destiny one for
inspiration which is like are you
looking at your previous game for
inspiration I think the wording there is
wrong for a question because it's not
inspiration it's like what did we get
right and I think that's the way they
phrased it they're saying they're
looking in destiny one end destiny 2 4
helpful data points they say it neither
game is perfect and neither one was
there's a lot of things we liked about
destiny 1 but there are some things in
destiny too even some people don't like
the tokens but if you think about tokens
versus reputation opens you can just use
them across your whole account so I'm
actually okay with that general idea
yeah so I was like but there's things in
both games that need some help obviously
some bigger things indeed to just
decisions were made and the community
was not happy about them right they're
just saying they're trying to make d2 as
good as possible and it just takes time
as they said before in their whole
development patch update process the
bigger the change the longer it takes so
things like weapons slot improvements
that's not gonna be a month it's gonna
be taking king or taking Queen whatever
you want to call it they're trying I
mean but all these things all the
questions they're answering I feel we
have heard more from Bungie since
January 1st of 2018 than we probably got
in the last three and a half years yeah
no absolutely don't listen
now here's your question let's go well I
can't the mobility stat increase sprint
speed I'm a hunter I need to ninja hello
let's talk about it let's go basically
what he phrased it as is our goal one
point one point for us to get back to
more of the d1 style movement especially
the movement with you're working with
mid combat now mid combat we all have
agreed fallout plays did his testing so
when you're strafing if you're 80s it is
noticeably faster if you're at 10 and
even says it below fun fact any mobility
value over 5 after one point one point
four is faster than the max Mobility
base speed values of d1 so I mean if
you're at mobility 10 and you go full
out on hunter you're strafing back and
forth you're gonna be probably hard to
hit in the middle of battle but on the
other side we called it the go fast
update for a reason it was absolutely
and they said they dug into making
changes for sprint speed now the reason
they said they couldn't do it they're
into some technical challenges that kept
it from being possible to get it up in
time to test with it's something they're
gonna still consider so they actually
tried it they just couldn't do it right
now so and they do understand all of our
thoughts to be like we want to go faster
why can't we sprint faster they tried it
when you have mats off or at least
letting us know not right now but in the
future so yeah I mean not to be that guy
I'm trying to be nice here it's 1:00 on
things which like okay if you fell there
were technical challenges let's do that
sentence writing technical town
challenges that kept it from me
impossible to get it up in time to test
with okay I'm gonna give you I'm gonna
give them the time deliverable excuse
but you know this needs to be revisited
you know I'm saying like it does it's
inexcusable of me of you they had that
ability to do it then you know it is
what it is but I'm you know I digress
that's just me they're out of state
right now where everything's gonna be
monitored I'm saying today they're gonna
have to do something and I agree to that
point it's I don't want this to fall to
the wayside and just be forgotten about
I also would hope at some point they
also revisit the other stats as well and
maybe that's something they're just
going to lump into a full change so like
maybe if we can't do it now we've got a
full revamp on something else so we'll
do what we can but we're gonna do a full
thing later if that's the case and it's
a change fine but if we're sitting here
a year from now and like the stats
haven't really changed the speed hasn't
actually been addressed again at all
then that's where I do find an issue
with it so it's okay to let me know
there's challenges with doing it but let
me know it's like we're still gonna and
they say they're going to consider it in
the future I'm like hey we're still
working on it is the phrasing I want to
see yeah and I respect that respect
what else we can that pretty much covers
the questions and then less we could
also went into weekly crucible playlist
so basically to sum up they mentioned
that having the weekly rotation allows
them to take a week's worth of data
maybe do some quick changes now when
rumble came out it was eight players and
it was abs
insanity now it was kind of fun usually
things aren't moving that quickly but
also happened where people are spawn
camping words or clips and you'd be like
I'm gonna stand in the store way this
guy spawns am i right this guy spawns on
my left heavy heavy weight again and
they don't wanna go that far and it was
terrible so and they said okay rumble 2
is coming back it came back this week
down to six player account they changed
this bonding policy behind the scenes
and that was in a couple of weeks that's
one of the fastest change I've ever seen
them that is true we've had three ask
Orton we got that one it was like sweet
sweet see they're gone more back in
action so six player rumbles literally
going on right now
mmm-hmm now they also said iron banner
is going to be coming next week actually
now this thing this update was saying it
was supposed to come but it got delayed
so they flipped it with rumble but it's
actually coming next week on the 17th
mm-hmm so we'll be coming but it's gonna
be six players on each team now the
reason they said iron banner with six
people won't be quite as bad you're in a
team it's not everybody so the spawns
you know they may flip nice yes
absolutely gonna be quite as you know
insane spawning next to somebody because
you know it's gonna happen a little bit
more with your team anyway mmm-hmm
then we run down below and iron banner
so if you're looking at an on screen
this has been delayed but it is coming
out the 17th so at this point it's
coming same information is coming those
who got control iron banner 66 and
remember with control now they have
changed it so you do not start with any
points active oh also on control you up
to three people can help a point get
captured faster which is good but if you
have more people on a point means more
chances for those supers to go kaboom
yeah we talked about this we love it
this little grenade launcher can I just
chop this little guy out of the corners
go stop again glass hand cannon scout
rifle pulse rifle auto rifle shotgun I
don't need you
yeah I don't know I'm curious to see 66
in an Indy - so happy fun I'm looking
for oh he's also looking forward to it
yeah man just this one one that's
classic 66 get the action going and I
like anyway I like that it's unique Vai
and ban it makes I am bana feel special
yeah it's like it's one thing that was
honestly it's one of the first times has
actually been a little bit different
power level supposedly mattered in d1
but honestly it never mattered enough so
the fact that at least in d2 they're
gonna say hey this is the 66 mode then
we come to the Destiny community summit
mention because people got invited and
then it came out on Twitter and the what
is happening what is this thing so it's
just a quick recap of what the Destiny
community summit is gonna be neither of
us got invited in the mostess it's got
its game ladies came late that's all I
was like but it's gonna be the 19th and
the 20th so it's gonna be soon now we
probably won't see what happens from now
for a little while they may get to get
their hands on the expansion come up in
May they may get to test it but really
what they're looking to do is getting
feedback from players earlier on in the
development phase so they're working on
whatever is happening in the fall right
now and we'll talk about what's coming
there right they want to get feedback
now while they're literally in process
and may still have some time I'd make
changes or make updates to things later
so that's literally what it looks like
they're gonna be doing which is good
we're good I mean I like to do listen
you know they didn't get the best I was
a flashpoint crew but you know I got a
respite my chest but oh the end of days
like listen the guys they got for all
their respective shout out the pole
shout a couple guys I know it that it on
it you know these are true destiny guys
these are guys that's gonna really dig
deep get into it and got our best
interest as the player base in mind so
you know is I'm very curious to see how
that goes through I want to see also if
they're gonna be under NDA most likely
probably are yeah I think what they were
yeah they probably been any
the everyday listen you I trust those
guys enough those are like our destiny
pillars right the people who have had
the community on their back for so long
and know what this game is about know
what it takes for it to be fun yeah I
think I think that's good you know and I
because at the end of the day it shows
the critical nature of you know quote
unquote to taking Queen or whatever that
big dlc that's gonna happen you know it
me it has to be perfect
they have to hit it out the park you
know and we'll get into that too as far
as on that in war mine coming up later
absolutely trust but dropping the name
there what are you sorry it's there's so
much but that pretty much wraps up the
week nine fall scores are still insane
if you're going for those the strategy
they say will only last until one point
two so they're gonna have a fix for
those loss sectors so actually gonna
make that better I was like I hope they
fix the loss sectors cuz right now it's
kind of annoying if you're going through
a nightfall and until you actually get
into where the respawn zone starts
happening you don't get any points
yeah sucks oh it really is annoying but
I didn't sold on my first prestige the
other night - oh he's back working on it
not fast and not high points but at
least I killed the boss so solo waste is
progress so that is one let me close
this wonderful tab and move on to deed
dropping some bombs here on Wednesday
that's good honestly where I was talking
with kognito like during the week really
he's gonna wrap this thing Friday
afternoon and we like we record this
thing Friday morning
push it out and then Wednesday it's like
I was like yes yes talk about things to
talk about so as the April as the March
came out the March patch came out one
point one point four we've got one point
two on the road we're like where's the
rest of the road map guys oh we finally
got an update to it where's the
Christopher Barrett was he's like he's
excited to extend the road map now the
big thing is things can move set in
stone until it comes out so take all
this is somewhat of a grain of salt but
if it's on here at least you know
they're working on
and it's definitely like there's a
bulletin board it is a big piece of it
yes sir
so let's just jump in this girl man
so season two we are gonna be basically
done with that one here in less than I
must go fast now does go fast that was
the last patch for season two so season
three will start with the official name
of the expansion is warmind oh it is
official and here yes pics looks hot man
it takes me back to my favorite reroute
to the machine no let me I just thought
about that one of my favorite parts of
that raid descending down those long
steps the beautiful lighting a little
seam in the back let's see what happens
so we'll get to that picture a minute by
the way if you guys check out the
current weekly update we'll get there
there's nice 4k version of this image
it's currently my wallpaper nice good
season 3 1.2 so with the expansion May
8th we are going to be first getting
seasonal personable rankings yes yes I'm
excited how they're gonna I think it's
just like - in blooms keeping track of
them so it's a step maybe they'll do
ladders later on cross my fingers I wish
butter rankings are coming gives you
something to play for in crucible now I
can hope it's more than just a ranking
maybe if you work your way up to I'm
going for random cuz it looks like it's
just an in bloom with a number on it
lets you get up to a thousand say maybe
you get an emblem you get it a skin you
get something if you get up to 1500 you
get something like to see some incentive
for getting higher as opposed no there's
nothing wrong with bragging rights
yeah but I'd like to see more for going
for those bragging rights and for the
people who get up there into the badass
level
let them show something off exactly Sean
baby maybe there's an or maybe there's
an aura attached to your emblem now when
you get to 2500 oh it's awesome let us
show off there we go you need a crown on
your head or something if you're up in
that elite
I mean in that something they already
have the systems for Lord crucible you
got a good cogbi can't crowns just us I
don't know I paid Bungie a lot of money
and I got a crown I'm just kidding
private matches are coming which if you
like playing private matches that's fine
but to me is it's not for me but I'm
happier coming to like a crucible
scientists out there I may have all our
plays he's gonna be very happy he won't
have to drag random people into that
definitely helps for testing and weapon
numbers and things like that here what
does that do from here these videos are
gonna be sick because you know he's
gonna break that bad boy down with
exotics and all type of perks and
attributes and I just love it he does a
fantastic job out of the four but I
gotta get him on a show many fantastic
job no vault space increase I cannot
wait to see what this is gonna be and if
it's enough all as you see right now is
Destler Gary's face
he's just literally like just like on
the desk doing the finger tap thing it's
like when it comes if it's like 50 slots
we're all gonna be like if that's all it
is we're all just gonna like bash our
head through our monitors then we'll see
but yeah I guess when I break my current
monitor it's time to upgrade to 4k or
something is that how that works yeah
you gotta do this guy's it must happen
I'm waiting for monitor to come out
actually
so 4k 144 hurts like g-sync like all
that stuff so it's absolutely stunning I
have it on the accident yeah they are
beautiful so now here's where the
changes started to happen from what was
in 1.2 so we had exotic
actually sorry I'm one step in exotic
master works are coming good missed one
backup multi emote we all those are my
dances man
dude I've been waiting for this I've
been low-key like I'm not gonna get rid
ridiculous but that is a big deal flag
so we could express ourselves but so
long I mean division had it all these
are the games have it so it's like
destiny who arguably had you can make an
argument as the best emotes in gaming
yeah there's some of the best for sure
in Italy let's go get my Michael Jackson
on and another dance I think more you'll
just be able to go you'll string things
together and people get a little bit
more fun with dances or little videos
and be like hey here's a think about how
fun that's gonna be in just regular you
know Guardian life in the tower in the
crucible on strikes just the funny
things people are gonna come up with
because they can string three or four
their favorite emotes together and
hopefully they'll at least put two or
three of them I'm assuming bottom left
and right you may leave the up one by
the fall or what I will see out hailing
the at least three should be an option
so more variety and just leaves a little
funny like even after crucible kill
moments instead of tea bag and you can
just do like some ridiculous thing oh
it's gonna be up tell he's gonna be late
man these are the type of things there's
a little quality of life but it's gonna
add so much I know I'm always just
always stating emotes but I'm telling
you shout out to Crisco he said motes
FTW that's right I mean that's what
makes destiny destiny it's the fashion
and it's being funny right you go up to
a person in tower he waves to you you
like you know you know then you start
dancing the next thing you know you know
whole club breaks out at new monarchies
dance party music sound beat or whatever
but that's the type of things that make
destiny destiny I'm glad that they
actually finally addressing this as d1
women wings that so I and maybe emote
will hopefully there's some new II new
like badass demos oh you know they are
that's a never verse would be ready
whatever
she's ready for it all exactly so I
heard you got more slats you got more
spaces I got more so I got more that's
31 and that emote you got any more of
that exact I'll tell you right now this
is where I don't mind Michael Jackson's
dancing for emotes i will spend whatever
is it I'm sorry like when the Michael
Jackson one came out I think I brought
like what was at 5 8 bucks it was an
expensive one but I was like I'm not
buying it yep get that one all right so
exotic master works those are coming
hopefully we can start making some orbs
with the other stuff and very clearly
yeah it was just gonna be the same for
now don't seasonal vendor progression
not entirely sure what they're going for
here curious very curious what that is
yeah yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see if they have like a like a tier like
you know I don't know like a number you
know I got like I'm like a level is it
gonna be like leveled or you level them
up and very chaotic I mean they kind of
have stuff now with the ornaments that
you grind through when you open 10 boxes
as well you can finally get the weapon
like is it just now you're gonna do
seasonal things to go with that I don't
know yeah that stuff in that pool oh
yeah
but hopefully matters yeah absolutely
not just like another reskin of skate
walk over here for the e DZ that just
has a different color on it yeah so
here's what here I was one step ahead
before so here's where they started
splitting stuff up to summer versus 1.2
yeah so before they had said exotic
weapon and armor sandbox changes right
now it is just the weapons coming from a
so I split it off which hopefully means
as we talked before exotic weapons you
know they need some changes they need a
little more powerful but armor is where
the gameplay really starts yet change I
think so I mean reworking that's fine
this is not gonna like change the game
per se like September's the big one so
if you take this upper to get those
exotics feeling a little better and make
the ones that come in in September as
well and cool so I'm absolutely in favor
of this because this is my opinion
marks the first time correct me if I'm
wrong he that exotic armor is actually
classified as its own thing and that is
a big deal to me I'm actually very happy
that that's been separated you know and
that they actually treating it something
different because that has always been
an Achilles heel with our destiny
medicine box tough armor exotic armors
would not get touched it would really be
very rare unless they were like
completely broken then they'd get
addressed but as far as buffs and stuff
like that it always came down to the
weapons and the armors need love very
happy some is not that far from me I'm
good with that
yep I'm on board so don't have to argue
with me on that one but it I mean it's
it there's so many more options per
class everybody gets the weapons so the
fact that you have so many more options
I can understand it taking a little
longer but just don't pull a nightfall
unique rewards on me yeah don't do that
don't take longer and then not make it
worth my while even though everybody
seems a lot this hand cannon right now I
see a lot of people grinding out there
shout out pyro
yeah just pyro pyro gaming he was on
like nightfall 22 last night still
nothing for him or his buddies Iverson
that they both play with I played with
them they both run at 22 times still
nothing is real no it is the rewards are
real I'm fine with it it's one of the
more unique looking guns I'll give it
that it looks I can front show it's a
doggy a heroic strike modifiers are
coming I'm Wyatt why do I run heroic
strikes right now why would I run heroic
strikes yeah I mean it because because
now the strikes don't have unique strike
rewards and that's just specifically now
boxed into the nightfall yep what is the
grind for doing like they finally add it
but what's the incentive enough in this
maybe it's said and this I there's so
many things maybe they're doing all
these little pieces here
they're so Slyke semptember is gonna be
like we built all the stuff in the
background we put up the frame of the
house now we're gonna set the new house
on it like I'm kind of hoping that's the
idea of what they're trying to do is set
up all these little pieces underneath it
so when you implement a brand new thing
and hopefully pull some people to come
back for like a it's the brand new
destinies you know so many changes that
all these things are in there so when
you come back and you know extract
modifiers are there this is there I've
been doing stuff so I think you're right
I think that's exactly because obviously
it makes no sense for them to come back
just by themselves without any reward to
to grind for so I think that's what you
said like they probably can't do
everything at once let's separate it
let's let's add it and then you know
September boom everything that you know
kind of flows in and those new execs and
new systems are in place so new
landlords yeah so hopefully but for now
I mean you have a milestone but if
you're max level you don't even care
about those yeah at this point so doing
heroic strikes it might be fun to see
what the modifiers are and be like hey
maybe it's a crazy one will like see
what it feels like but I'm gonna go just
grind strikes for hours that's not house
there's nothing you'll get exactly and
the nightfall challenge cards we have
them so I'm not entirely sure what's
changing you don't have muscle on this
one mm-hmm oh I don't know if they're
gonna change it more because I know they
said it was basically nightfall like
prestige nightfall challenges and stuff
it was like 0.9 they were kind of in
like a beta phase they were testing it
with us so maybe this is more modifiers
and things like that that they're gonna
put in there no no mm-hmm
it is kind of annoying right now when
you're doing the challenge card you
actually if I'm doing a solo and maybe I
want to crank up the difficulty really
high but I don't want the kickback to
orbit I can't turn the kickback orbit
off I mean I know prestes is hard but it
was like if you put it in there you're
still forcing if you're doing prestige
if you all die you're going back no
choices so yep if I wanted to grind and
say you know make that give me even a
higher score but right now it's just
there so mm-hmm give me more options
maybe it was you know solar cinge and
juggler and whatever like - some could
plus I'm good - like have a little more
creativity with it you know you give you
a little more
variety for the week and somebody like
Daddo could do all right we're gonna do
some and change challenge with juggler
and light switch and everything
seemingly finished that type of stuff is
I kind of able to go yeah
completely agree maybe that's what that
is I'm hoping I remember at one point
they were saying that we're not quite
done so my hope that's what that is okay
fix it summer which my wife's name so I
shot some satellite view we've got some
more things coming so we've got a new
seasonal event mm-hmm excuse me once we
usually have crimson days we'll have all
the lost will have the dawning which
came in later so what is it gonna be in
the summer like Munster in the world has
their Spring Festival going on right now
what was the name of the d11 wedding
brought back the Wraith I was a cool
rock back the raids they had a name for
a bomb come blanking right now wasn't it
like Blanken it was something that if
trying to celebrate the end of be won
and it ultimately you know I mean kind
of put the cherry on a Sunday we got all
the old rage back up to high level we
got the cool gear age of try it wasn't
yes well they can't be dating there's no
triumph here Indy to do it's been so
long since these bid that girl I can't
remember babe yeah that was the cherry
on the sundae or do you remember now so
but new seasons have been something
along those lines so they'll be a theme
there's gonna be something going on ever
verse is gonna be like I got stuff for
ya so we'll see what that is I don't
know what the summer is gonna be I mean
they like overwatch has done their
Olympics festivals and things like that
so they'll find something yeah if I said
I won't be supper oh you know what -
once again Sparrow racing
oh yes we have a nice barrel racing yet
indeed - it's gotta be spare race it's
gotta be back that's my gut I'm going
with power racing there's nothing to be
triumph or triumphant about the idea
podcasts here when they do it's like all
right it's an in-and-out bet you ever
heard those yeah do it what you said
what you got what you got would you
think what you're doing new seasonal
event in summer is I just doubt it's I
just add it's fair everything so wait so
you going with a real event then going
with I'm just going with something along
lines of like festival or crimson days
something themed around like summer
weather or something like that if it has
if it has it in there I'll be buying you
a drink
foreign and probably a meal as well so
I've also got a pull of control over to
my PC because as much as I enjoy that
that's the only thing driving a sparrow
just feels a little weird on PC and
Daisy a finger on why we go ahead with
this bed but summer event like I say you
your fans bear arisen I sneeze bow
racing I'm just saying something that
doesn't have Sparrow reason okay okay we
got faction rally improvements we know
they're pretty lackluster right now
besides of paint jobs and ornaments so
hopefully they're I mean yeah yet some
pvp fights against each other a
real-life score like a live scoreboard
something so we'll see what happens
there now here's one I did not expect
what you got
Bounty's wow that first of all I got to
come at somebody right quick
my boycott series he would fight me
lorica bots who would fight me to a nail
in d1 about how the been mounting system
it's antiquated how ability to get rid
of it it's just extra work going back
and forth and look where what we have
that the community has spoken
now I mean it had to happen it had to
happen bow knees because it gave you
reasons to do specific things you would
not
normally do those things put you out of
sometimes your comfort zone you maybe
you use a subclass you didn't use a lot
or fight enemies in specific areas it
made you do stuff in the world doing
stuff in the world creates engagement
that is what is missing from d2 this dis
dis I mean you actually do your basic
missions and once you do you blew it up
good up d2 right in these days right you
hit the left trigger first cuz console
peasants not you about this you know you
see all the things you have to do in a
corner yeah that's nice and it's
convenient for them you know yeah you
said six to seven like you said you know
what you do you call on you do your
nightfall you do flash point that whole
thing's done if you feel like I fly
through that in a day or two a group
doesn't a raid like if you literally hit
all of this like no more milestones
you're like oh there's no incentive to
do anything else now if I go to a
specific NPC or you go into the town you
got bouncies which gives you either
rewards to experience on what have you
this is what I'm talking about let's go
this is that's a big deal balinese
coming back is another big deal I'm
about it man
no it's like I'm down to because I mean
you could picture so say shacks is gonna
have a couple daily bounties maybe some
weekly bounties some as well now what it
was I just so shacks please bring back
the true meaning do like do ten daily
boundaries you can get in right call and
say there's like three available a week
Clare a day so bring that one back give
crucible a to get some nice rewards yeah
but what find another way say there's a
say there's a weekly bounty from Zavala
where you have a public event on every
planet oh let's go and have those what
trials have bounties yeah and say if you
do that maybe like you can I don't know
weapon token give and give incentive
behind those bounties and again set
yourself up for September to have
all these little facets in place so when
people come back hopefully cross your
fingers if the world doesn't hate
destiny but bungees got that hype Trey
and I got faith
they do man I've never seen anybody
happy games like about as well as they
do so you don't got marketing teams on
fire that's never been an issue no I'm
saying the marketing teams on fire it's
just shout out the Attic he's like we
want this so bad yes we want it so bad
shout under like your voice what up yeah
man I mean I'm with you man I think the
marketing teams gonna be fine with that
but I think this is a huge deal yeah I
like it I mean if I do and and that's
the thing I'll read plenty of people
they'll be like you know there's not
that much reason but it's like if I'm
bored and I jump in real quick and you
just run around in the world and shoot
stuff nothing
nothing feels better you give me
incentive to do it or you give me a bar
to fill up a progress bar we don't want
to fill up that progress bar
fanox PC clan chat should have been
there thanks it's finally coming mm-hmm
exotic armored sandbox changes so
there's I'm time um er so as we were
saying can't wait that's the really
curious what they do that's for me I
gonna lie to you but you have to read in
someone some I mean listen you know one
boy what you call it - it still is still
though you know cuz that's gonna be in
conjunction with new content so I can't
understate that may 8th is gonna be late
in that respect cuz there's so much
stuff I like okay I say so much stuff to
do
crossing my fingers we don't have a
curse of Osiris DLC we press situation
where they should know they don't give
us a space that's as small as a circle
is gonna be other things and give me my
damn Sparrow word don't cuz don't try to
create that illusion of a big space they
didn't - which was still bigger than the
circle exactly so but some was low-key
might be for me
no seriously whenever they do some
summer patch and just the fact that they
have plans for summer summer is
typically empty for this game it's like
til September we're pretty much off they
might do like they might change some
night well that's when they did daybreak
before they did like the less a break
was all they're up in September's
they've actually got stuff planned for
summer so
I can celebrate my win over you and the
pet get my drinking fool I'll buy you
the drink you can buy my food house that
I had they would doubt I will say glass
of wine usually cost less than a steak
that's all I know in spare racing is
there I'm gonna be happy so it's like
finally season 4 September now September
is what they're claiming and I was
giving you a look like I was saying
before it's like hey I don't know and I
still like I want to see how these next
faces go how warm lined is released is
gonna be big how that expansion feels
and things
what September is something large is
that it's a major expansion big let's
keep it real this is this is the one
this is the one that has to save destiny
destiny three I would say because let's
be honest the weapon change people are
waiting here we're gonna spoil this is
the bigger revamp the biggest revamp of
all that they can possibly do so um yeah
I mean this this is it and we know what
they're up against you know it's tough
out there and he's gaming strong and
there's so much this fall so much I mean
everything's getting pushed up you know
and um you know it it's no longer the
one you know trick pony I mean one one
team race and they mi most base and you
got the battle royal games and you got
you know um in September now you know
red Dead's October they gotta get it
right it's worth and it's over like it
is completely over like there's no doubt
about it so it's gonna be man Liz I say
made a tie they gotta get it right as
it's me
so that you keep that goodwill going
okay all right no build a little faith
going into the war nope I was like and I
honestly I wonder
you had to pick one thing on the list of
warmind stuff that would make the most
people happy what would it be and I've
got one you're probably not gonna pick
the same one all right so you don't
mouth with September whoa no oh wait
what is the one thing in May that people
like think like this like this is one
thing in there that's gonna be like you
know that's gonna build a little face
but you know that's gonna keep people in
the back of their mind saying okay I'm
waiting to see what's next after this oh
stop that list I'm gonna meet one no
like one all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
surprise you I doubt it because I'm
probably gonna surprise it's not gonna
be as much as I'm gonna I'm gonna go
against the grain you probably don't
think I'm gonna say the weapon slot
thing move up the weapon slide
deliverable oh no I mean that's not
happening that's not happening right now
so what I'm gonna say is Dave God oh I
want my boy gaming addict back that's
what I want so in order for him to come
back and this was actually trending on
reddit today I looked at it and it said
raid lair has destroyed the anticipation
of the warmind raid because at the end
of the day you can have this great story
you learn about the war mine we learn
about that but the thing about past DLCs
is that you actually fought the Wraith
and the location the story of the DLC
was in yeah because of this stupid raid
lair we know we're going back to the
apartment 2d in the Leviathan no one
wants to go back to the libido you've
learned this lesson curse of Osiris and
I'm hoping they throw you a curve ball
and actually don't yeah what our part
was going on man so it's like here's the
thing and attic is completely right I
remember we won't I lost podcast shout
out the mister negative hit me man
negative or going at this is when raid
layers were announced right we didn't
know what a raid layer was we said we
were gonna give it a chance it's a
three-part thing be on the Leviathan
yada yada yada yada right here's the
problem when you play curse of Osiris
you had this supposed great story you
know the Egyptian name yada yada yada
story ends there's no indicator there's
no reason to go back to the Leviathan
but somehow the game is making you do it
it's connection
it disconnects you so it needs to be the
end I think they need to doubt they do
this but they need to bite the bullet
and say you know what
story-wise just just doesn't connect it
doesn't connect so let's put the raid in
the war mine in Mars
put it in Mars make it or raid not a
raid layer cuz it no disrespect to the
last one I don't count it I don't even I
don't count that name man I don't care
how great the boss is if we didn't get
to the boss in that quick I was like
what - basically room air to a small hub
areas yeah it's not rates cutting
corners
raid layers I would say he must die but
in my opinion I need gaming addict back
he would be so excited if there was a
full fledge you know I probably won't be
taking Kings now but at least I say if
they pull over at the machines down yeah
wouldn't you want that
oh I mean both those were also Marines
absolutely
so that that's my require now I'm very
curious about your request
no well you went off page I was going
for literally what was on the list okay
let's go so for me the one that I think
they would actually like give people
like a thank God moment mmm-hmm vault
space you give me like proper vaults
like multi emote yeah you want to dance
you want exactly exotic masterworks
they're cool sandbox changes we don't
like but just the fact that I don't have
to log in and manage my inventory every
time I log in absolutely fix that
there's annoying and we got to keep
using third-party apps and those are the
foolish man angry I see that was I was
gone for a funny moment there but yeah
you weren't all serious and I had
- cool now honestly agree and Mike I
crossed my fingers hope that they're
actually gonna throw you a curve ball
and be like yeah on the raid sitting on
this planet it's like all the regulars
are gone yes oh I want a cinematic
Attila brought the back and blowing up
or sinking like the Titanic that's
season four when the darkness comes in
shoot planet eater out of the sky
there's a new ship outside of necess
exactly yep yeah throw money at the
screen so you can see that one throw
money at the screen quick reddit yeah so
well for September we've got a couple
things the many people had asked about
and then a couple that I'm kind of
curious so gear collections is number
one yes you think this is like kiosks or
do you think it sets like I had talked
about I could hope it sets but
unfortunately I think it's kiosks I
think it's chaos I hope it sets don't
man I mean they need that in the worst
way No
so we'll see records so record books
coming back it took four it took taking
King to bring a white record book in the
first time mm-hmm
so I'm sure this will be something
similar mm-hmm and then the big two
we'll just talk about them all together
weapons lot changes weapon randomization
bold there's huge so we know weapons
lots people have talked about we've
talked about them before to into the
community just as like I want options I
don't want just all primaries and
everything lumped into this other bucket
where I own Indonesia yeah any options
give me variety so we know that's there
yep randomization that's that's a big
one huge I mean that's taken a developer
that sits on stage going hey we're doing
all this we're finding a way to make
your tenth one okay we didn't figure
that out we're gonna go right it's
literally complete
he's stepping back on your launch of
eight-game I mean and that's what you
thought you're nothing being like we
screwed up
mm-hmm that's gonna be a Coppola that's
the man I mean absolutely shout out the
puncayshun Casey I miss destiny so much
I will play the story on the new
expansion just hope somehow someway it
pulls me back in pretty probably things
man that and I'm curious I want to ask
you because you can put this in the chat
what would it take cuz we want to pull
the community so what would it take
specifically is it the weapons fire
we've yet to rank one thing if they
fixed that would get you back Punk put
that in the chat and when we visit cuz
I'm very very curious about that but on
the way back to you know the September
thing with the season season four it's
just like you know this is a big deal
you know weapon rounds and I think this
is the reason why honestly I want to
stay pushed mods off the deliverable
from may remember mm-hmm and they moved
it here because I think that's gonna be
it
my gut tells me it's not gonna come back
in the way everybody thinks well of
course there was gonna do a Bungie style
exactly III don't think it's gonna be
all the way old-school d1 when you get a
gun through rng you know boom it's
different from the next guys I think it
those perk that those mods are gonna be
part of it and it's just gonna be see
how they implemented and what level see
here's my thing and I'm gonna go for a
slight long point tangent sorry here's
my thing and I don't want to be
disrespectful it can't be as minut as
mash the work stat adjustments yes
because as much as I love master works
let's be a hundred this the actual work
that the orbs are powerful yeah oh those
are crucial those powerful however the
actual perk adjustment is so minimal
it's a joke you can't even notice that
it has to affect the gun you have to get
a better Devil's or something that you
know really effect
makes that gun different I get the
reload speed gotta be crazy or if it
comes and impact the impact like we're
borderline breaks it because at the end
of the day that's what you grind for
right even want that guard role we don't
got God rules man like that's a problem
like that's what people played I was
upon that was the game within the game
yo I got a grasp him a lot he got head
Sica and it got such a size right a
strike like oh I must have vaporized
that boss with like a tethering to
celestial golden guns like 20 times in a
row there's I mean they had like the
carrot on the stick mastered facts real
quick punk answered my question
weapon rolls he's nice but for me wild
array that he's just like a dick he said
on what the world needs to be better
I want gear and weapons to drop after a
boss he said the key [ __ ] has got to go
they worked they went back to him trying
to put your ops back and not the Chucky
Cheese tokens
yeah they got big they definitely worked
on that since you've been gone
but the radii agree yeah it's fun he's
gonna be interesting to see how they
handle war the war mind raid I know for
sure let's say this by September we know
for a fact we're gonna get a new raid
and it can't be the Leviathan let's just
say that no that won't all be for sure
yeah but what you got would you get
events I mean seriously though it's like
when you think about everything that
could come and you think about the raids
a lot of the things they didn t won or
what they saw as issues in D or in D 2
or is what they saw the issues in D 1
okay so people are farming checkpoints
for specific things we want to you know
make them play so they put the central
hub in the raid and you have to go from
the rooms but I always come back and
fight the same thing yep I
you can literally look back at do you
want to be like I can see where those
ideas came from for some of this okay
when bouncing is really hard
random roles let's take him out okay
that didn't work so it's like they've
had like a really rough year of learning
lessons to say things we wanted to try
and fix things we thought would help or
make things easier or whatever not a lot
of them worked
mhm so I mean you're coming back to
people not liking right layers
you've got weapons lot
changes that are either gonna be d1 like
or maybe even a fourth slot you've got
randomization coming back via with mods
or perks or both I'd like to see both
honestly all of those things it's
setting up September if they can get
enough of this stuff done to have real
potential but I think also as you said
if there's even if it's like 80 percent
great and there's something that like
starts rubbing people the wrong way like
that 20 start person it starts getting
under people's skin there's so many
things that come out after it they're
gonna have a hard time holding them and
they will anyway I think it's gonna be
hard now do they set up cept with a
December thing to follow it to try and
pull people back like you have all the
holidays you've read dead going on
you've got a month of November to play
Red Dead coming up the holidays okay
December 15th expansion like they got to
I think got to me if they follow
protocol which is the classic protocol
December has to be another you know what
you call has to be another expansion it
has that's that's the Activision Road
Mac slash protocol so if things were
going good that's what would happen so I
mean in based on the fact that they
still keeping the September day and
remember me and you we talked about this
at nauseam like should they interested
in it because of the state of the game
is so bad right now so they just push it
out of that window and they're sticking
to it so yes we'll see
and then I guess we'll kind of see if
then you roll into like January you're
kind of like alright now I got
everything I got overwhelmed the played
some games what if it popped out now
like it'd still be kind of curious it's
like I know it won't obviously be
September's there but it's lately you
know we'll see kind of we'll see how all
this goes they're setting up a lot of
little pieces like random heroic strike
modifiers counties like bounties in and
of themselves in a random summer drop
they're not people aren't going to come
back for that you're gonna be back for
mine but bounties on them their own but
bounties with a release in September
with like a reworked quest system like
taking King has with weapons Legends
with randomization with potentially a
new class or a new subclass or all of
those that's a lot of crap combined
everything with a solid foundation that
they've been trying to do since they
figure it out they screwed up
no I mean this could you know see
hopefully the stars can align that's
where I can phrase I mean listen you
nailing it I mean I just it's one of
those things that yeah on individually
as themselves they don't Wow
but in combination and let's just hope
that September is that taking Queen DLC
is what it is now you've got all these
things that we've already put in place
from May is summer there's a chance
there's a I'm not gonna get guess it's
letter of hope Slayer that I've hope
that they may be able to get it right in
and the thing that I'm hoping that
really feels good so we talked about
earlier that summit that they had all
the top guys in the community the guys
that know this game that breed this game
that had what we were grinding in d1
with they know we all know what destiny
needs we know the life what makes
destiny destiny so that if they combine
all that with the feedback then there
should be no reason why doesn't come
back the question is is it too late the
question is it the competition this is a
different beast out here you got
fortnight in these streets you know I
mean you got all these amazing great
single player game shots got a walk
coming
you got you got its competition destiny
is not the only thing in town that could
be able to definitely be able to
withstand that because it was so good
you know now because of the state you
may have lost people for good so we have
to see how that does and then one thing
I do say I will say though I am
confident that the marketing is going to
be lit that's one thing Bungie knows how
to do is market the game so I expect
fireworks at e3 I expect them to get as
hype many people will be like up
November sorry there's gonna be people
die say that there's no doubt about it
alright there's also people who haven't
touched them for be like okay that
sounds cool exactly then we keep doing
flashpoint and we put out that episode
would be like hey guys what is nice like
got it you know say you know we're gonna
be the first cuz we've been doing this
in the dark ages right back
Bob the flag hi hope it yeah absolutely
so a lot to hope for and I mean May 8th
is not that far away far away not that
far away then like I said it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting to see what
war - I'm very warm on actually is more
important to me I'm curious to see how
they handle story and raid it's very
curious
I mean the story is a big one because
curse of Osiris it had to be it had to
be made in like a month
I mean I say that I have no idea how
long it takes those guys come in six
months we gave you everything we could
we're trying but the planning I know
something so much here so much is
already playing in advance you guys can
tell how long a sandbox update takes
like when you have two strikes that are
literally here's two missions and the
strikes are the same thing that
literally that literally means you don't
have enough time to do it there's
something happened but you know where
her daddy had the white I had to mess up
Bob is this waiting to see shout out the
Jake wasn't really he was on a TSP shout
out the pumpkin and guy they volunteer
speed and they were talking about it was
just like you know how many people
wanted to see Osiris and have that and
four I'm gonna just fumble this I like I
almost want to do over like I almost
want him to make a cameo in another day
because it's like it's just like uh but
anyway I digress that let's see what the
war man does
I will tell you this though I would like
to see some Seaver back I would like
some simplified stuff if possible that
would be quiet
I miss Eve I mean I miss what you call
it the arm rattle machine ray no those
are feel-good moments for me in reserve
iron so if they I can get a little bit
of old feels in conjunction I would feel
good about it I'm okay
seeing Siva oh but oh it's something
different like we have seen the same vex
hobgoblins
say five nights for four years
understand it's a universe but there's
it's a it is a universe
I want vex I want a little more variety
they say new enemy types didn't isn't
the verbage in the sounds like it's
somewhere in here and I'm trying to get
to where I can read it so hold that
thought so but that's what I want I want
I mean and they even said it so I got to
get there so I can read crazy you want
too much they do that do it we'll see
mm-hmm
nope so they also mentioned they say hey
they now have a plan for raid prestige
changes including rape layers which
unfortunately means we're eight layers
is plural probably means we know what
war mine's gonna have oh I've loved if
they did a raid layer and the raid just
blew everybody away but that's way as
much development time and it will update
the next development route so and we'll
update where it will land in the next
development roadmap map it's not even on
the roadmap for me mm-hmm
where is where is that but they also say
mod changes are being incorporated into
our new plan for weapon I randomization
sighs you said it's in there now I'd
like to see more randomization perks and
mods so like hey there's this gun I can
get but I know this one mod can help
with this so you can customize on both
levels give us all the ways to customize
cuz yes
maybe it's like this you know this god
to your player can play with the scout
rifle that has a bit more kick to it and
with but have a little more powerful
part maybe I switch and I just wants to
own a laser I want like a laser Scout
right like pulse rifle and you can just
like go spec it full stability just if
we get more options that way I'm okay
with it
mm-hmm hi great so we jumped ahead we
dropped the name already a couple times
with his head the expansion for season 3
is called war mind if you guys again
want this there is a nice 4k wallpaper
it looks fancy yes it does so here's
where it says and it will send you to
new places to meet new heroes and battle
new
enemies now new enemies for season two
or for destiny two could be Siva because
we haven't seen them in here yet we've
already seen taken it's the only thing
we haven't right it does look kind of
Siva SH but also just war mind it's just
like that could be just what an AI looks
like back there so but I know what the
war mine people feel save us what's
definitely has that shape to it so we'll
see season three marks the beginning of
our new plane to deliver a crucible
content so this is actually kind of cool
they're releasing all new crucible maps
being developed for war mind into
matchmaking same goes for the maps we've
released for curse of Osiris so all maps
will be in matchmaking for everyone
whether you have it or not so it's a
bigger player base nobody is gonna be
like sectioned off if you don't have the
newest map or whatever everybody is
going to have the same maps and same
options so honestly that's great the
only thing is to do private matches you
have to buy the expansion to see the new
maps but honestly bother me one bit
because I'm so Angie like this and
listen let's be real you know they're
not in a position right now to be trying
to segment in community with maps based
on to play a base so I like that you
know even if you didn't buy the DLC you
play crucible you'll see the new
crucible maps in yeah yeah so same thing
as before this just like post-launch
content expansions new campaign new
destination new destination roads new
raid lair I want this to be something
else but we all do now so okay let me
ask you this I know the raid layer was
lackluster because it was only a couple
pieces and we did get a piece of one now
what if for example they pull a
combination of say both d1 expansions
say we get a raid lair let's say we get
like a POA activity with warmind the
fine POA activity I mean literally
almost like a horde mode it's like you
have a war mind to say you go into an AI
thing almost like what is the thing in
x-men Oh
top but it's like it's something where
it's like it could even like make things
that just like that you could work
through but it's just like it's a warm
line so it's a giant AI so it could
generate things that you could do almost
in like a setting like that and it could
just be almost infinite like say that
rate layers there but it also gives you
something else and again this is the
expansion numerate coming later and
maybe they'll get the feedback that they
don't like the raid layers but I still
have a problem because at the end of the
day is weird story just gonna listen I'm
gonna tell you right now this is where
it's gonna discuss me we're gonna play
this content great scenery great
backdrop let's say the story is
fantastic then at the end somehow are
you going to live I had I'm gonna see
that the gold font and I'm gonna see
cabal that have nothing to do with
anything I'm gonna be upset no I can't
argue with that I was just asking kind
of carry us but it's like as much as the
concept of raid lair
I guess you know I don't think they can
do that for season 4 ok I don't I don't
think it makes sense late does it make
sense to me I must just keep it I'm
calling it I'm a call to space pain
sorry bunny oh my god I think it's lazy
lazy development I think this is the
real reason why we have Rea layers is
that let's be honest a raid in their
defense takes a long time to create yeah
a really intricate is extremely
time-consuming and the way they looked
at is like look man we just can't keep
pumping out these raids each time so how
about somebody came into boardrooms hey
what about raid later like it shouldn't
have been the place but they knew they
couldn't meet the deliverables this
again let me see I shouldn't say I know
I'm theorizing yes they could not they
possibly felt to themselves these things
are too kind
look at Wrath machine you know now it's
just made by arm yeah I got delayed that
was made by you the live team right yeah
I mean
yeah so - what if we want something on
taking Kings scale see this is where I'm
okay with them pushing back DLC you know
I mean if they push it on when I'm sorry
you're okay with it nothing in September
what listen if I get a full rate no
partment to A to B to C no more it's got
to be a full-fledged rave you know you
know you know how I knew Destin really
fell so hard besides the fact everything
else going on when that raid layer came
out no really cared about the world
first be honest like kid that what's the
name of the boss we don't even know the
name what is it
our goals right this noce there's no
story but it just feels so pieced
together in Ashley a strike in kind of
intricate strike it's a glorified
six-man strike just call it what it is
and they got to get rid of it now they
may not be able to get rid of in time
for warm I see attic attach a trailer
needs to be free of the spring and it
said never place to take place of race
amen it can't come back September
no more layers they've got to know this
the numbers indicate no one's really
doing it if you got a good rating desta
you know many times you play it way too
many but that was also the thing that
hurt it too there was an incentive to
play it right why were you going in d1
to play vault of glass over and over
back because you could not get to max
level Vandy other way any other way and
it had unique drops absolutely some of
the best looking armor in the game at
that point and the prestige had a
different cool set like don't read my
glowy but tell you this is what it is
when Leviathan for as good as I don't
think the vines are bad right I like
Leviathan now like but when you're
telling me to go back in there just
because I'm gonna get a different color
on my legend a curious you've lost me
yes I'm not doing the dogs with six dogs
or eight dogs for for that yeah for
flora Brown
sooo yeah I was like anything about the
orbital prime quest that worked
cuz at the end you got the gun you
didn't have to again you you had done
the raid so much at that point yeah you
you knew it and then when you got the
gun after doing all the different pieces
and this and this over here and all this
other crazy stuff when you got it you're
done when you do legend of Icarus you
get like stage one you're like now I
gotta go do the thing I've already
grinded for to do it again either right
at least three more times to level it up
and they're terrible terrible handling
terribly terrible rewards okay so it
sounds like for you raid is like your
big thing even season four just a real
raid not a raid lair nothing connected
so mine I would and they mentioned a
piece of this in the weekly update but
it's not the way I wanted it to be
mentioned what I want is for you to get
max level
it's gonna take some grinding at the
hardest content it wasn't destiny one
mmm-hmm I mean if I don't want forever
21
I like the progress they kind of a
spoon-fed it they've been making it
easier and easier and easier and that's
I did not let and that's what probably
took me out of this game the most my
buddy was doing the right a little more
than me cuz I think he just played a
little quicker like in the first week or
so but I was doing some public events
like when I was up and he was sleeping
or whatever in off hours I was still
doing public events I ended up getting
same max level without touching it then
I win a level mm-hmm you're taking my
whole incentive to do a raid to do the
endgame content to get there are guns I
don't have but I don't have that
progression that final progression by
doing the hard stuff out there so that's
that's my point I want you to start
reading those don't spoon-feed to beat
max level where I want that and they did
we're gonna address that they do mention
something about PvE bouncing they were
gonna touch but I just want to shout out
to Attica to chat he says he doesn't
mind a railay have to go over story but
see attic I still disagree because even
if it goes with the story which is dope
like don't get me wrong I'm not
discounting that if it connects with the
story don't but it's a
can't be that short because a layer
ultimately to me just a few hub worlds 2
or 3 you get to a ball you know a
mini-boss or whatever it is you know
like they put it this way if their their
layers each layer has to be on the level
of Leviathan that's that yeah I mean
that's my thoughts do it yeah absolutely
if it's on the level of Leviathan it's
automatically it's a it's a continuous
story that seamless that flows
absolutely ok said not general but
taking place all right yeah absolutely I
agree with you got again absolutely
definitely fill you in that if they do
that I'm cool with it yeah they can call
it whatever they can go with this you
know the raid condo or a terrorist I
don't care what they call if it flows
and it has the length and the weight of
content and meet of content yeah
absolutely yeah and I think this comes
back when they had that narrative lead
posted position poster we had that whole
long description about story and it's
like we want it to connect that includes
that includes the strikes as well give
me heroic strike modifiers
I want give me a reason as we progressed
we even did that before
yeah like go through here's this planet
you go through okay here's the like give
us or reason to make things connect so
you're like oh I remember this point
when I was in the journey what's been
that plate I came across Kade and it was
on Nessus and then I had to go do the
inverted spire - yes like him pull it
into the story mm-hmm and I know they
want this game to be a first-person
shooter but too many your people that
love this game too much need it to be
more of an RPG even a shooter yeah
absolutely God or at least be a hundred
pursuit errs is there you guys haven't
nailed no question but you've got to
pull that RPG stuff up equal to it at
least absolutely so the rest of the game
continues to make sense because there's
too many people that aren't just I'm
gonna be a color duty shooter person
like go type in it's not fair to say
that yeah but in turn it's just like I
want that whole game to I want it to be
a cohesive thing a cohesive thing you
wanted to matter you on his story and
into their defense I felt there were
some attempts
with Leviathan I felt when we for the
first I remember gladden we flew in a
cinematic wanna fly okay
you know the boss talked to you at the
end you know it was cool it was a cool
attempt you know me when you started the
gauntlet he'd laugh you say alright cool
you made it like a game show bean cool
but every raid has to be like that plus
more and more cinematics you do that you
get people emotionally invested they
want to play that raid all the time you
know I mean yeah we had and that was
that I guess that was the thing about
the other raids every raid had more than
one boss ah thank you
a man fights we didn't have rooms with
ads and mechanics now if you had rooms
with ads mechanics and then you brought
a boss out take the bath for example do
the bass do that whatever and then say
whatever like where that center section
is where you shoot those three you have
to do that and then you go behind it and
then there's a boss fight just the same
way it was the warm or my work no or
priest so you have the totems that
unlocked and then you have the boss
fight so there's mechanics to get to it
but then you literally have a boss fight
thanks we have to have boss fights you
have the you have the maze you have the
dark maze with the pits and like the
numbers and open doors then you do go
over ah yes yes you know I mean hasn't
remember we call them affectionately in
a war machine the cable that the TV's
behind them
yeah you know he was a great boss I've
got his name TVs and then you throw
it'll be throw the volleyball he played
I know Vasya classic was dope yeah Roz
was a good boss they need goes yeah yeah
yeah I mean that's the siege engine was
in a sense a boss fight because but I
mean that was actually almost less of a
boss fight but it don't make in the
scale of a boss fight it was cool
everyone worked together you grabbing a
part it was cool like they've got to get
back to that man they've got me bugs
we're like okay they're elite dogs you
just have to do a lot of damage but
gauntlet you
mostly running and shooting ads I mean
it's just it was they went so they went
taking king mechanics so heavy but
forgot the big guys so he acts and then
shout out to you got me in chat I've
talked to her for a while another PC
player will woo but she did she was like
Kings fall was a great raid and it was
an actual raid it was a bit long and I
think and for some people was a bit long
but that's where checkpoints come into
play they got rid of like checkpoints in
Calais with the rate in there because I
don't you always have to go back to that
main room and I think that took away
from aggression bility yeah repeating
that thing three times you're like okay
fact you go to the underbelly and skip
mad stuff like it was no there's the
iSchool idea like you were there yeah
like it was a cool idea the underbelly
was honestly really really really cool
because it sticks with the theme of the
ship and there's a giant like I love all
the ideas behind that but just give us
some more progression so yes agree what
else yeah yeah told you guys 1.0 we back
baby two weeks off Long Point this week
at Bungie I also I love this picture by
the way so this is your tree
improbability to strike the war minds
like oh I'm here what's going / but I
have figured this one out for solo and
prestige so yeah
anybody got meas like make the
underbelly as an aftermath of beating
Calais absolutely do that and give them
go wonder around and like you have your
some secrets that way I mean it's cool
have it be just an unlocked area you can
go wander around after you be through
the first time just like the like going
to mercury when you finish trials it's
like so then you have like the main raid
landing then you'd be like okay now I'm
gonna go into the underbelly like it's a
kind of a different point you're gonna
enter it from a different area and then
you're gonna go explore a different
world like if you gave us something like
that there were some ads down there are
some cool secrets that be the like
that's the only place mainly with
secrets on all destiny too
is the rate and most people were like I
don't really want to do the rate so
exactly
I completely agree so this week it
bunchy yes we covered the road map you
guys know and here it is if you guys do
on a wallpaper right here you got 1080
and 4k looks epic crisp images art team
I wish I had the skills you did I will
never be there so awesome sauce keep it
going keep going but may 8th that
arrives the stream of the reveal two
weeks before on April 24 it's fine for
literally 11 days away from it yeah
we're right there right that close
eleven days what eleven days developers
from Bungie will be on hot seats along
with summer natives from our partners at
Vicarious Visions shout out to Vicarious
Visions
really if you ever come into town I'm
gonna sit you down at my computer and
let you play on PC on a good rig and
you're gonna be like crap go back I'd
listen don't you try to tempt me to keep
the devil out of my house don't you
tempt me with their 4k 60 know what you
do it you have how you doing well I mean
it's console present I don't wanna say
I'm gonna want it then I'm gonna it's
gonna be a problem and all my clan is
here I can't stop being evil about to
stop it I gotta poke the bear and see
what happens but no seriously what I
will say about Vicarious Visions porting
a game to any other system be it be it
switch or portable or PC is never easy
and that's a worry that some people have
a monster underworld for example is like
Capcom ports sometimes suck from what
I've heard I've no idea if it's true or
not but one of my buddies things like
they don't always get those right so the
fact that Vicarious Visions i just want
to shout them out they nailed the port
they absolutely nailed it if you've got
a powerful PC it runs and looks great
that's why I mean the particle effects
and things that are added in there that
just give it a bit more pizzazz is cool
well just the fact that it is still
destiny to every letter of that word
that is what I wanted to thank them for
so just shout out Vicarious Visions that
PC port crushed that absolutely shout
out to e have given me a sub Wow
man let's go I appreciate that
trust me any and all support to either
of our worlds be at iron Lords podcast
he's on YouTube doing the same thing
live right now is awesome
so yep so pipe power okay so here is the
weekly update they're talking about
they're changing the power level how it
affects how you're gonna face enemy hmm
now this is kind of what I was saying
they're giving more this is some of what
I was saying is good so it's not all the
way there right so I don't want us to be
handed max level but the fact that level
is going to make a bigger difference
we'll see now it says normally it was up
to 40 power levels Delta there's gonna
be a difference between you and an enemy
now they're gonna have it's worth 50
power levels between you and an enemy is
going to for one make them immune
I'm glad to see something like that if
you guys go into the wrong area yes it'd
probably get worked max that's a d1
staple when the guy you shoot the guy
had the question ball goes that you knew
you were not strong enough to be there
yeah I mean and that's like I mean take
anything if you guys have ever played
anything like blood-borne and you wander
off into the wrong enemy you're like oh
smash and I'm not starting over like you
learn lessons but that's literally like
that gives the game gravity that gives
the enemies weight that makes us like
here's another head I'm gonna pop off
yes I mean absolutely on that type of
stuff so that's good I like going but my
only question is I'm kind of curious how
they're gonna implement that so yes so
basically they're saying 50 powers or
level is gonna be the difference it is
40 right now now if it's 40 right now
people are still prestige again
nightfall mm-hmm like 45 down I mean
here's some points where like if Jackie
on shoots you with a sniper it's gonna
be a one-shot as we go let's do it two
or three basically oh I mean I
understand where it definitely gets
harder my only worry about this is I
don't want it to just be an artificial
difficulty the way they made raid
enemies level 33 when we're level
32 oh we gonna fight I like that we
gonna fight right I like that because
this is my side well it's just fake you
say artificial number like make him 32
but I mean you have more health but it's
just you were easier to kill they were
harder to kill but it's just an
artificial number don't make them 33
that's hmm so so what help me understand
your side
help me understand like your main thing
is you don't want the power gap but like
the enemies I'm confused but don't make
it just artificial by saying it's like
okay you're gonna be 33 and I could
never get up to your level so you can
make an enemy difficult I'm not saying
that you can make difficult hard to kill
that's fine but don't make it artificial
to a point of like you will never be
able to even match them okay no no we
want to say okay forever unattainable
right right you can start me at 300 in a
raid make it one piece of gear and maybe
be 305 310 315 3/2 and I can grind all
the way up to 350 and they can still be
kicking my butt at 350 but when I get
there but when you get there you should
be able to squash them now it should be
on a level where you can handle where I
can like it where I feel the difference
yes I know I'd be completely
unattainable outside of that range right
my targeting what you said I don't know
you are correct it has to be attainable
that level once you get there you have
to be like it can't be there forever
always going to be you know that step
one you like it have to have to equate
that because what it is is again this
goes back to leveling and feeling
powerful once you get max like level you
know mean it should be it's gonna be
easier still with that system but at the
same time it's still gonna be a struggle
right so you want it you want to feel
pile you want you want to be rewarded
for the fact that you hit that like
level so it should be a little scale
back in my past I do ignored you in that
sense yeah
so no fight we subsided we're getting
Society you got me in chat like level 29
to level 30 that one
for that hardmode raid that made a
difference if you were all 29 or what
was it going in I'm trying to think
going into the hard mode raid the first
time it was the people like had five
people go through one finished and came
like however they did it like they had
somebody get to that max level I think
that was later on but the 29 to 30 made
a difference as soon as you finished
your full set because I was 29 point
like eight I had everything but the helm
26 okay thank you I mean I was 29 point
I was like everything but the helm I was
stuck in it and as soon as you made it
30 you finally got that final piece it
completed your set and you actually felt
a difference okay so I want the I want
the enemies to be difficult that's fine
what raid are you talking about which
you made the difference just curious uh
level 29 and 30 that was well to class
okay
yeah but the other pieces don't hand me
the difficult don't hand me my level
right what I want to fight for that
level I want to feel accomplishment to
get there and I'm it's like and I'm and
it's awesome if I walk into a little
like if you walk into a raid like have
you ever played World of Warcraft no I
haven't but I know the concepts yeah so
I mean yeah most people but it's just
the idea of the question question icon
there's literally some of those rate
raids are huge and they have like 10
bosses to them sounds amazing first
alright so as you progress through like
if you go in the first couple areas
you're working on getting gear that
people only get for weeks like you work
on leveling up your entire group then
you can work on that second boss because
you try and go to like boss three or
four you are literally not capable of
doing it absolutely but I got I got
something else I want to add that I
think we even forgetting about besides
that which everything you're saying is
100% accurate and I'm completely agree
with it besides that what made us feel
powerful was the fact that when you beat
said ready said equipment helped you in
said rate yes so it helped you it said
encounter like kill Oracle's faster kill
all goes faster I remember you know the
ratted machine when I fight Vacek I had
the chest that you know reduce damage
you know when you arm that boss yeah
when you're holding a bomb
so you can take more damage it you have
to get into it now I know they kind of
did like a band-aid one way it's like
okay and it's power I shouldn't say been
it is powerful the stuff that they've
added right now for Leviathan class
items powerful everything else for me is
not counter powerful right it should be
specific like okay well I shouldn't say
I because some people do like the fact
that it you know on count you know its
class and it works against the wall like
double down on that yeah just get my gun
but is like hey this works better on
Oracle's yes that's an extra mod slot or
an extra perk on the Ray weapon but put
it on the weapons exactly like does
double damage against the dogs yeah
let's go why is this such a you know
when on plates you know whatever like
you know you doing plus something damage
in the Shadow Realm do extra damage to
the floating skulls like mmm-hmm okay so
that means it's like hey this you know
this auto rifles are really good against
the skulls I don't have it this is gonna
grind but when I get there I'm gonna
know to switch out and get ready for
that fight exactly it made you wanna
wear the gear it that was so key my
remember feeling a sense of pride like
yo I got the boots for this when I got
the on well you know I'm doing or at the
machine yet you had the head because it
it dig shot cannon and you move faster
nobody gloves they gave you all that
heavy oh my god so much one is some of
the best raid gloves those ray gloves
ever you can't fallen enemies and he
gave you so much heavy like they've got
to get back to that and don't be afraid
to have some of those perks still be I
mean you're gonna make raid specific
perks but making an addition to don't
take away from perks just have it adds
so when you take it outside of the raid
it's still beneficial as well you know
still have the slot still have that in
there but give me that raid perk as
you're saying put on the guns
put on the armor let my head be like
what if on my helm or something like
that you're gonna highlight some of the
enemies in the raid you're gonna
highlight the elites or something like
just throw it on there for X and it's
like a little scanner like if you're
gonna go steve-o get technical like that
like throw the themes dive in go all the
way like come on like we want and it
we've seen
before we're literally pulling
information from d1 other games - it's
like you work with Blizzard you've got
d1 experience these are the type of
things that are gonna make stuff feel
special you feel how you want to feel
special with your you want your gear to
feel unique special engaging for the
content that you're in and I want to
feel like a beast
we might grind my ass off to get to that
level to use the language I try and keep
it clean but that is what is we're
passionate baby bash you know respected
man as like the Nets and that's why I
was like this is like I'm okay with this
right here levels the question being
immune if they're outside of it yeah but
again you got to tell me where that's
actually gonna come into play
right I mean the only time that that's
gonna be is if you go fifty power levels
on it like a nightfall and you lower
yourself that's the only thing it's not
you're right you're not a lot of places
where it's like if I'm scenarios mm-hmm
if I'm wandering in a patrol there's not
like a hard zone yes all the same level
about that before - like patrols like go
have the area by the Cabal ship on the
etz go bring that up to like them
nightfall level difficult just make it
hard like a wonder around and they
wander into the wrong place like yeah I
got around there's not one point in be
one where I had to turn around you can
run by everything you're not gonna have
something look at you and die it's like
the exact opposite so they've got a dive
a little farther into that I think a
great completely agree so they are back
in plaid no they did this last year that
was relegated this so they do a
shout-out to Bungie that was do some
awesome donations and those work with
children's is a Children's Hospital
right there I'm turning the names it's
like rice I hear them I know yeah
I always forget it's not seniors because
that's uh no it is thank you okay it was
the same but yeah they should be seen
yeah okay so I always do really cool
stuff so they've got mins and kilts
that's a good fundraiser they're doing
and it's a big deal for seven so they're
saying every $30 donate it will pay for
a family stay at a house for one night
so these are for Ronald McDonald House
and things like that
they have a goal of raising seventy
seven thousand dollars
awesome so by the way that's a hilarious
picture a lot of capacious hilarious
fake golden fake Gjallarhorn you gotta
like but it's really cool like if you
donate and you want to go all-in and you
want it like it's pretty sweet so you've
got high-res art you've got postcards
digital prints like exclusive art that's
gonna be done then you get up into the
high stuff for a thousand bucks you can
participate in a bungee studio visit
with you and a guest which is awesome
two thousand bucks you get the studio
any custom piece of art as well and it's
all going to charity it's awesome but I
was like I mean if you you know you want
to make your donation to a really good
cause you can get a chance to go see
studio you have to pay for your trip but
you are gonna go get two visits Bunji
like i think anybody who's played this
game is like please let me in the doors
yeah it's really awesome they're also
working down here with the wellspring
family services similar things here
so it's the gauntlet tabletop fundraiser
similar prize pools so you can get just
all cool stuff here so check it out guys
if you're looking for a place to save
donations just always cool stuff so
check it out you can get some cool
destiny gear apparel art a visit
depending on how much of a baller you
want to be so step like even if you guys
drop ten bucks or whatever just you know
throw some word out there if you're
fortunate enough to be like you know
sitting on a computer and listen to a
podcast with a nice cell phone or
whatever it is take a second take ten
bucks 20 bucks out of your date donate
it to people who need it because you
never quite know other people's
situations and it's just a really good
thing to do facts facts facts emotional
segment of the seriously like I mean I'm
thankful to be very fortunate with my
life and I'm very very thankful for that
so it's like when you can when you're in
a position to do it by all means do it
isn't it you never know pay it forward
give mine give and it's gonna work so so
as we previously mentioned
iron man I had a little bit of a rain
delay he got called on account of rain
but we got it back April 17th gonna be
going live at noon Central Time one
o'clock for you killed afternoon wake up
uh so it's gonna be 66 it's gonna be
control all the weapons are gonna be in
there so just they switch it they
figured out their glitch and they got it
solved and in a week they figure out
that Clips not like iron bands down
impressive
no trial situations no I'm looking
excited for Ben six we see I'm curious
we're still looking for the bigger stuff
you got me in chat was saying one thing
that would slow down the lost sectors
and nightfalls make the enemies in
sectors 50 levels higher than the
nightfly used to be extra points done
done
yeah just go in there like when you
spawn into a nightfall you spawn into a
strike it should be able to load you
into like a server or an instance
basically and yeah if you wander in
there make any any I like that like
definitely yeah make it to immune then
you're like alright then you fix your
problem again not a developer sounds
easy but I wish but yeah they do load
you into an instance though and that
instance has to count for literally
everything from start to finish the
enemies all those pieces the spawn times
all it's in there yeah when they're just
say if you're in this zone over here of
the world you're gonna get your butt
whooped so agree we're gonna form this
thing did it crap I just got smashed
what happened it adds value to the
content it makes it a difficult piece of
content we're all code that that was
like I mean division did it and we know
Division two is coming I want to I want
to see those patrols have more value
than just like public events public
events public means let me do a hard
public event then let me be let me
wonder if I want to crank it up to
heroic difficulty if I'm like so long
and I'm like maybe not because I'm in
the hard mode I'm gonna get squished
mm-hmm I'm with it man they've gotta
push the boundaries with stuff like that
yeah use your content
use it it's there oh so I got a couple
patches bug fixes things like that
I said I'll always have Paris so they've
got a couple videos here a couple of
funny-looking ones
mmm so this week the top score I didn't
want to point this out 481 points
difference damn this one data back weird
there you gotta pull that up I believe
you know there was like there's a link
on the one and it's broken now oh it's
broken
okay changed with only two eight one
it's literally a link and I'm looking
some imager thing and it's gone some
wonder if somebody put a little Easter
Egg in there that kind of got deleted
for a second as possible yeah but that's
close like I don't know some people are
farming those that's crazy - to me the
dudes would be falling crazy just for
that that is insane
people when they name in lights on a one
the flop I guess whoa next update is
only a month away stream is on the 24
that stream is in eleven eleven days
y'all so we got a lot coming guys yeah
we got warmind less than a month I'm
gonna be seeing like a new to have that
afternoon off cuz i'm gonna be playing
bill and blue in the face yeah for new
content new level
perhaps mm-hmm 350 360 400 see that's
one of the I will say for most of the
expansions they've ever done you never
be giving me a big enough level to grind
to FSO to 300 to 330 even if it's three
thirty to three fifty or sixty it still
never feels like enough just give me a
good around 400 yeah it's just go all
the way out with it you know yeah in
chat two weeks off at the end of May to
grind yeah you're gonna be just chillin
that's I mean and that's when it comes
to set that's one of those things like
if I went out for the community summit
or if you know there was ever a question
it's like you make the girl they're
afraid of I guess making something's too
big or making expansion mean too much of
a difference that is a point to an
expansion like PvP normalizing
but if you're gonna go into new content
yeah and and to me now is more no more
excuse me no more issues now because of
the fact that they've made it that
people who don't have the DLC can still
access other things so reward the people
who who did pay yeah level in chat as
well it's like they're saying okay so
say it's up to 360 another 30 levels
fine 330 to 350 20 levels normal grindin
going through the last ten give me a
challenge make it harder don't make it
artificial the way you level up a
character in 264 you're like well this
slowed down like a brick wall brick but
at least just make a progression or just
be like hey you got to go do that
in-game get those last 10 levels
something like I just want to see that
come back a little bit I'm completely
agree man there's a lot of stuff we said
today yeah Long Point War John an hour
and 51 minutes so we hit it but it's all
good with the cover we want I mean we've
got expansion coming we've got bolts
face we've got exotic weapon changes
we've got o emotes I'm sorry I skipped
over that dad do it but also we've got
like bounties are literally on paper
screen per se but it's on somebody's
sheet of paper mm-hmm yeah like bounties
is one I could like they talked about
weapon slot changes their bounties I did
not expect to expect it I got to get him
credit for that one didn't expect that
so we're peaking in the right direction
yeah it there's some hope we got the
community summit crew you know we got a
DLC the key is gonna be even if I can't
be there can I just send a drone with a
microphone just I can listen I want to
be a fly that rooms so bad I want to see
things that I fought over I want to hear
it I want to know what wins out you know
I'll see if I can speak to some people
yes and era like esoteric like shadow
nightfall so the beast mode like say he
unfortunately just can't put things
together and go and I was just like
one of the best nightfall solist out
there it's like oh so it's like but it
was cool they're like I don't think he'd
ever been oh I mean the fact that they
were reaching out to no farther
boundaries of what they had before not
just your big streamers and stuff like
that so they got a good selection in
there and I think I mean PVE pvp big
streamers like hopefully there's a good
variety and I think if they listened to
the community that are there those are
the people that live and breathe it even
yeah I trust they live and breathe this
game there's no question that's Cleo you
know do we know we know dad was on it
dad oh and I'm sure he is a lot listen
if they got my man Holtz dad oh I mean
those guys I think are up in steam we
know Pope is on it
who was confirmed so far that we know
I'm trying to think like and I'm just
thinking of like names and there's so
many I can't nobody need my head we can
wiggle all right now buddy the other day
I am confident that crew has destinies
back best interest at heart
we're in good hands now it's just a
matter of the implementation and it's
just a matter of may DLC will it be
enough cuz to me I'm telling you about
as if may it's poppin' if war mind is
popping if woman has a good raid that
builds goodwill you know I mean even
though September we know is the magical
moment with also to come together it may
is a good one
people get confidence back people you
build that trust like okay they may be
getting it together now you don't know
if you do another curse of Osiris leave
a bad taste in a lot of people's mouth
for something most people have paid for
everything up to this point yeah a lot
of people want the season pass yeah most
people are in there locked in attics
locked in there's bad people who because
we were so high we bought both of them
off the jump both expansions for that
you know for the cheap yeah but we can
see like I think in chat
I think Holtzman's in there she said
watts is in there dusty red upon
watching the release Holtzman in it nice
yeah so I mean you probably got the
whole destiny community but I got DCP
yeah the holding key probably dado
probably turtle I got it I'm good like
fall out I mean I would guess fall out
guards going crucible yeah so I mean you
just start going through the list like
some of the big names and then hopefully
just yeah there's some like solo solo PV
ears like esoteric got invited so I mean
I get to go I mean it's like dude I feel
like we were in good hands for September
yeah
so I'm hoping so between now and there
say there's more yet to be revealed so
they've got more on the table for
September but it's like we want we want
sorry yeah Medical right for that go
consult life aging there's a tripple
wreck but gigs but yeah it's a good mix
so yeah I mean there's there's a lot of
hope it's anybody who has played destiny
long enough that still steps in the game
it's still fun to shoot stuff in there
and I think we all just once quality of
life and we want a reason and that and
that
I mean quality of life is thing like
vault space reasons bounties gear that
matters weapons slot we want the reason
to grind we want a reason to be in the
universe because we we all there's so
much it's so funny when that January up
like update was coming out from Cosmo or
whatever like I even tweeted out the
tension in the room was like just like
so it was so much that like they
couldn't win the bar was so high it's
like and they have been working their
hind quarters off to give Jess more it's
supposed to be so it's like I just I
can't wait okay wait let's see what
happens now like if it doesn't do it for
you if you enjoy warmind for a little
while in like hey I'm still waiting for
September you got a lot of other stuff
to play so do it I'm being come back and
I'm hoping September's that time people
like hey I picked up a couple day games
is November should I go check out
destiny too
my hope is that I can say there's a lot
of stuff in there you really should be
sad and that's what's last poised for a
long points in the books yeah
all right well yeah for everybody out
there either in chat I lords podcast
check them out for sure you just look up
iron Lords podcast you'll find them I
got some awesome roundtable discussions
over there on Sunday got some good
content from pax nice stuff yes sir yes
yeah getting out there in the real world
seeing people face to face hahaha
yeah Megan I love interview on you know
news reporter live on the scene
IOP news a little square picture on the
mic be like we're from CNN we're from
ILP pax was great we will be the Lord
will be in the realm this Sunday no
guest this week but it's gonna be our
packs recap we'll definitely talk that
we've got some great topics the four
horsemen will be in the building so it
will be great it will be Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time on the inner
circle network please subscribe me there
at the roundtable and the lab chat is
always a fun time you guys don't find
that great topics and we gotta get a box
back on the show soon to probably around
me what would that be xi okay well I'm
just guessing because that's three days
after that expansion right after the a
will be flashpoint which we'll probably
talk it to death anyway but yeah May 13
summer and am happy comeback I was trust
me I still play I was blessed with
playing Celeste on my trip this weekend
that's like what super meatboy but
actually with some story going to it so
it's actually pretty cool I liked it
thanks
oh yeah that's a guess for the week
enjoy your play time could probably work
on probably a solo proceed see what
score I can actually attain with
something reasonable I finished it just
not very high score but I'll be working
on that one you guys always follow me on
twitch TV slash Avant is Twitter YouTube
subscribe hit the alert Bell likes
comments you guys know other good stuff
find any way to support us shout out
again to ihab in chat
nice thank you for the sub that was huge
didn't expect that from this well yeah
that's pretty much what I got guys what
about you Kamino
you know me at Lord Cognito on Twitter
as well
I know Xbox Playstation is our cognitive
360 switch my social security is
somewhere but you can you can do me
there switch you can add me through
their new service which connects those
media but that's all I got man we found
another flashpoint aka Long Point in the
book looking forward to next week it's
gonna be fun we'll see what else this
game it's got cooking up all right guys
good afternoon good morning or evening
cuz you guys could be all over the world
where you listen to and you think we
thank you from every corner of it have a
good one peace